I must have talked about that before,
but that's definitely an in Max Tivoli.
There's a lot of passing.
He is a different age than he appears to
be cause he's aging backwards.
So he,
he's always pretending to be something
else.
And his friend Huey is passing and
there's the mme who's trying to change
herself.
Um,
and then the story of a marriage,
there's a way in which the book is
passing for a while.
The main character doesn't reveal things
about herself and a lot of the
characters.
Um,
I think certainly for Max Tivoli,
it was very much on my mind for that
time period,
that turn of the century,
19th to 20th,
it seemed like the moment when emigrants
could transform out of their own
stereotype into an Americanness and then
America was ready to
ready to believe them.
Um,
when a lot of groups we're able to do
that.
But I think there's something kind of
sad about it too,
to leave all that behind.
So I was really experimenting with what
was complicated about it because Max
gets to do a lot of things and have his
heart's desire,
but he pays a great prices so that
everyone around
you,
it's hard to know.
It's very good.
Curious thing.
I don't think any of us ever thought
there would be a black president phil
nominee as of yesterday when we're
taping this.
Um,
Aye.
I,
but he's,
he is,
he is not hiding his race in any way.
I think he's,
something's happening where a lot of
people are accepting him
mmm.
On the terms he's talking about and he's
not pretending anything as far as I can
tell him.
I mean,
he's a politician,
so he's pretending everything in a way.
Um,
but the line he's drawing is one,
I'm prepared to stand behind.
Um,
and a lot of politicians,
I just feel like none of it's real.
I don't think it'll work.
You know,
I don't think people would buy it if he
tried to pretend that race didn't matter
because that's what he was faced with.
He had to give that speech.
Um,
and he could've said,
why are we talking about race?
And the steady said,
we need to talk about race.
That's what shocked me really got me.
There was a story that
my grandmother told me about 10 years
ago about herself in which she,
a friend of her husbands of my
grandfather's,
took her for a drive around Rural
Kentucky.
Uh,
must've been the early fifties.
And he turned to her,
he stopped the car and he turned to her
and he said,
Leona,
uh,
I was your husband's lover in the war
and I'm as lover now and I want to leave
with him and I want you to help me.
And
she could not tell me the rest of the
story because I think the idea was so
crazy and absurd that you just said,
let me out of this car.
I never want to see you again.
And it was all over.
She never talked to my grandfather about
it.
And she regretted all her life that she
couldn't have left.
But she always told me,
she said,
I had,
I had two sons.
I'd never had a job.
I was a poor woman.
I don't understand what I was supposed
to do.
She all the restrictions were honor and
oddly,
that's a part of the story I really
liked was to identify with the woman and
see how trapped she was.
Obviously her husband,
my grandfather was trapped.
If it's a true story,
which I don't know,
I'm grandmother told a lot of crazy
things,
but it doesn't matter to me as a
novelist.
Um,
okay,
he's trapped for sure.
We know that.
But what was,
what made her so trapped and what made
her life harder than his and a lot of
ways and that that was the story.
I wondered what's out.